hello everybody welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll today is the
third idea we're thinking about I
originally called it force but as you'll
see I expanded it to be force energy and
action
honestly this is too much for one video
I'm trying to keep the videos short and
punchy but these subjects kind of rolled
into each other so hopefully we'll all
make sense at the end but future videos
I'm hoping will be a little bit tinier
more excitingly I want to announce that
we have technological improvements that
behind-the-scenes anyway so of course I
don't need to work where the red shirt
anymore because I've figured out my
green screen technology a little bit
more even more important than that boom
we now have both a landscape format
horizontal format for the writing I'm
doing on the iPad here and also we have
a dark background with white writing
which many people have requested so it's
it's an experiment you know this is
actually probably more like what most
people do it's taken me a little while
we catch up to what people were doing
ten years ago here but let me know in
the comments whether or not this is
working for you also of course I should
mention this more often than I did but I
do a QA follow-up video for every one of
these so you have a question leave in
the YouTube comments or on the blog or
pick out some of the themes in the
comments rather than individual comments
and I will tackle them in another video
to come a few days after this one so let
me mention why I'm grouping these things
together you know we talked about how
particles move in classical mechanics
and particle by the way means a lot of
different things right okay the earth is
a particle by the standards of our
videos here today but you tell me where
the particle is its location you tell me
how fast it's moving and then using F
equals MA Newton's equation relating
force equals mass times acceleration I
can figure out what it's going to do
next but when you think about it these
words are not necessarily created equal
right I mean the position of an object
we can see it we know where it is that
seems very tangible and readily apparent
to us the velocity of an object well you
know okay we can judge when we see
something moving how fast it's going and
even the acceleration we can sort of
wrap our minds around but something like
fours
seemed like an invention
of human-beings right of physicists and
natural philosophers who said let's
invent this concept to make our lives a
little bit easier and energy likewise
right I mean Isaac Newton never had
anything to do with energy he never
mentioned energy even though it's a part
of classical mechanics as we now think
of it couldn't you just get rid of these
things and talk about positions and
velocities or momenta and do it that way
so well yes and no is the answer there
are ways of doing that and so it's an
interesting question about what is
fundamental what is real what do we
really need to keep when we're trying to
move physics forward so that's basically
the underlying philosophy of today's
talk to think about whether we really
need ideas like force and energy and
we'll get to something called the action
ok so remember what what we might call
the Newtonian oops the Newtonian
laplacian paradigm this is what we're
working in here and what I mean by this
is not just classical mechanics Allah
Isaac Newton it's in particular this
idea of Laplace's circa 1800 that all
you need to know are the positions and
velocities of everything at one moment
of time and then you can predict exactly
what's going to happen in the future and
the past and sometimes of course instead
of velocity we use momentum because why
not momentum in Newtonian mechanics is
just mass times velocity now it turns
out that for certain more advanced
purposes which we're going to get to
maybe in the next video momentum is
better to use than velocity but we'll
talk about the difference between them
later for right now as long as the mass
of a particle is fixed as momentum and
velocity are interchangeable and then we
call the set of all positions and
momenta
we're meant to being plural for momentum
something called phase space I don't
know why it's called phase space I know
why it's called a space you know we
think about space as being just a three
dimensional space in which we live
mathematicians use space to mean any set
that has some extra structure on it so
when you were taught set theory as a wee
child you were taught like if you have
an apple or pear in a banana that's a
set of three objects mathematicians will
say if I have the real numbers okay all
the numbers we minus infinity infinity
not only is it a collection of numbers
not only is it a set but there's
different operations defined on it like
adding real numbers together or
subtracting them things like that
multiplying them so that structure
promotes you just from a set of objects
to a mathematical space so space doesn't
mean three-dimensional doesn't mean
where we live it's just a collection of
objects often an infinite number of them
with some structure phase space is the
collection of positions and momenta so
we might actually write it as curly
braces X P this is what means all the
positions and all the momentum for all
the particles in the universe okay some
enormous dimensional space and then
Newtonian laplacian paradigm is telling
us that you give me a point in face face
I'll tell you what's gonna happen next
right so the rules of the game are you
give me you specify all the positions
and all the momentum some point in this
giant phase space and then I can
calculate the forces so there's a set of
forces acting on each particle and they
will depend on the positions and
velocities of all the other particles
and on nothing else okay so that's why
this idea that people's MA is so
powerful that once you're given the
positions moment of everything the
forces acting on them will be determined
by what all those other particles are
doing and it's from that then you can
determine what happens next because of
course the change in position is given
by the velocity
viii and that's already given to you if
you want it is momentum divided by the
mass and then the change in velocity is
given to you by the acceleration a which
is the force over the mass so if you
know the force someone's given you the
position some of the gives you the
velocity then you just chug forward in
time right then you can just say what's
gonna happen next so I have my set up
right now at this one moment using
calculus like we talked about last time
you can chug forward in time changing
both the positions and the velocities
using these other quantities that is the
Newtonian laplacian paradigm for
thinking about physics and by the way
it's not just particles so not just
particles it can be anything the earth
we often idealize as a particle but it's
really big ball right it's really big
sphere there's a lot of atoms in it
there's stresses and strains and
pressures and temperatures inside all of
those can still be accommodated within
the Newtonian paradigm if you think
about a cube of something you know jello
or something like that some semi solid
thing they can wobble around then what
you can do is take a little cube inside
and think of that little tiny cube as a
particle so it'll have some force acting
on it it'll have some mass it'll have
some velocity etc it will be acted on by
all the other little segments of jelly
right around it that are pushing on it
so you can calculate what the forces are
etc so this Newtonian laplacian paradigm
I phrased it in terms of particles but
it works for fields it works for
continua works for solids and liquids
and gases and everything that's why back
in before the 1900s came around we
thought that this was the right paradigm
for doing physics people had a difficult
time even imagining it would be anything
else all right it is something else but
we're not going to get that for a few
lectures okay well we want to do instead
is ask some conceptual questions about
this paradigm in particular why
position and momentum why are those the
things you need to know you could
imagine going either way if you imagine
other alternative laws of physics right
you can imagine you just need to know
the positions maybe you don't need to
know the momenta you could much more
easily imagine that you need extra
things over and above this maybe you
need to know the hopes and dreams of the
particle you know its goal in life maybe
you need to know its history like was it
sad did something bad happened to it
does it have a traumatic past to have
daddy issues maybe all those things
matter more mathematically you know we
know that velocity is the derivative
with respect to time of position and we
know that acceleration is the derivative
with respect to time of velocity why
don't we have more derivatives that we
could count as part of the state of the
system Newton says you don't have
anything more than that you don't need
more information than that but we could
imagine needing more information there
is something that we call the jerk that
is really what it's called I'm not
making this up
that's the name for the derivative of
the acceleration and fewer people know
this but you can go further there's
something called the snap which is the
derivative of the jerk so if you want to
think about it the position is the
fundamental thing in Newtonian mechanics
the velocity is the first derivative
with respect to time of the position
acceleration is the derivative the
velocity so acceleration is the second
derivative of position jerk is the third
derivative of position snap is the
fourth you're not gonna like this but
there's something called the crackle
that is the derivative of the snap and
there is something called the pop sorry
that is the derivative of the crackle
now as a matter of fact I have never
heard any person physicist mathematician
or anyone else use the words jerk snap
crackle pop in casual conversation or
even in technical that
without just snickering at it at the
same time like these are not words that
we actually use very much but they exist
you can look them up there on Wikipedia
and you might ask why when we're
defining what is the system that we need
to state what is the information that
will passes daemon needs to know why is
it sufficient to give it position to
momentum not also acceleration jerk snap
crackle pop etc well I don't think that
there's an answer to that question that
is simple and satisfying like at some
point you say to yourself the laws of
physics are what they are
could you imagine laws of physics where
you needed to know the crackle in order
to figure out what was going to happen
next
yeah I imagine you could I don't see any
obstacle - good - doing it there's one
little loophole there you might be able
to rewrite a version of the laws of
physics that did require knowing these
higher derivatives of position as just
more things going on but only positions
and momenta for those things those
generalize kinds of things but still you
know the question remains like for real
objects in the world for the earth and
for balls rolling down hills and things
like that we seem to just need the
position and the momentum so I'm not
gonna explain why you know I don't have
the reason why that's all that you need
but I'm gonna think a little bit about
what the implications of it are so I
really do think that the search for
figuring out why the laws of physics are
what they are rather than something else
needs to be a humble search you can't
insist that there is one deeper
explanation you will always hit rock
bottom like you could say well these
rules these laws of physics or the
simplest or the most elegant or the most
powerful or the you know most most
geometrically beautiful so what why do
we have laws of physics that are
geometrically beautiful etc beauty is
the eye of the beholder right if you
wrote a line Stein's theory of general
relativity which in its sort of native
tongue is one of those beautiful
theories ever invented but if you wrote
it in sort of Newtonian language you
would look incredibly non beautiful look
incredibly ugly so even if those were
true we wouldn't know why they were true
so at some point you have to say that's
the way it is but what would you can
talk about is what it
flies what what it means for how we
should think about physics given that we
don't know what all the laws are right
we're trying to do better all the time
so what this means what the Newtonian
laplacian paradigm means is the
following fact imagine that we put you
in a rocket ship okay so here's a rocket
ship but it's not firing okay so it's
just floating out there in space it's
got some fins to control its motion here
you are in the rocket ship and someone
asks you over the radio so they didn't
give you any windows you can't look
outside in your rocketship these are the
rules of the game this is how thought
experiments work sorry they asked you
the the radio comes along and says where
are you but all of your instruments are
down you're stuck in the rocket ship you
can't see outside you can't notice
anything that's going on outside is
there anything you can do to figure out
where you are no the answer is no not
without looking outside there's no
difference in things you can do in the
rocket ship between being at one place
in the universe and being in some other
place in the universe if you like try to
like do local physics experiments you
know measuring F equals MA and throwing
baseballs around there's no difference
in the answers you would get no matter
where you were located there is in other
words no preferred position in space
that is a feature of Newtonian mechanics
likewise if they asked you well how fast
are you going you might think you could
do that you could read the speedometer
or whatever but if you don't have any
instruments if you're not allowed to
look outside if you are just doing
experiments and looking at things inside
the rocketship you can't tell how fast
you're going either I mean fast with
respect to what if there's another
rocket ship going right next to you it
might be moving at zero velocity even
though you're both moving at high
velocity with respect to the earth with
respect to that other rocket ship you're
stationary so the moral of that is there
is no preferred velocity in Newtonian
physics either so by this point you're
thinking all right there's no preferred
stuff in Newtonian physics right but if
the person on the intercom said on the
radio said how fast are you accelerating
what if maybe you were
accelerating right what if there was
some rocket fuel going out and
propelling you in one direction could
you tell how fast you're accelerating
sure you're pushed downward you're
pushed in the direction opposite to the
acceleration because roughly speaking
you want to stay stationary your inner
rocket shift is pushed this way so you
feel that push going on you so there is
a preferred acceleration namely zero
acceleration you can tell whether you
are accelerating or not and this state
of not being accelerated this is called
an inertial trajectory right these are
the trajectories for which momentum is
conserved and kinetic energy is
conserved etc so there's a preferred
class of trajectories in classical
mechanics if you want to think of it if
we draw a spacetime diagram right so
space over here time over here there's a
trajectory where you start at some point
and you're moving at constant velocity
namely zero
there you are you don't know where you
are
even though how fast you're moving but
that's an inertial trajectory you're
moving at some constant velocity
here's another trajectory someone is
moving with respect to you at some
nonzero velocity but from their own
point of view everything looks the same
they're just going there through space
they think that you're moving you think
that they're moving it's an equivalent
symmetric situation here's a fourth one
a third one rather this person is
accelerating and they know it
they are not on an inertial trajectory
so the point of Newtonian mechanics one
of the points one of the features is
that there is a set of things called
inertial trajectories and the space of
all inertial trajectories turns out to
be the same as the space of all initial
conditions it's its proportion it's
isomorphic if you want in math speak
equal to phase space you give me a
position in a velocity at one moment of
time I will tell you which inertial
trajectory you are on so that's what's
going on that's why acceleration is not
needed as part of the specification of
the state you're on once you know which
inertial trajectory you're on that's it
and if you're not on an inertial
trajectory just calculate the force and
it makes you go okay so this is you know
these diagrams and these words might be
familiar if you know a little bit or
even exposed a little bit about
relativity this kind of thought
experiment where you put someone in a
rocket ship and you say they don't know
how fast they're moving etc if you added
to these rules the extra feature that
the speed of light is constant to
everybody you would get very quickly to
special relativity I didn't mention
anything about the speed of light here
in fact this same basic set of words was
talked about by Galileo so this is
offering fir'd to as Galilean relativity
and it is a form of relativity it's not
Einstein's relativity it's not special
relativity general relativity is
Galilean relativity it's this notion
that you don't know where you are you
don't know how fast you're moving
Galileo wasn't talking about rocket
ships but he talked about moving at a
constant speed and how you wouldn't be
able to notice so Galilean relativity is
built deep into the structure of
classical mechanics so with that in mind
let's think a little bit so that that's
supposed to be a discussion of why it's
just positions and velocities again we
can't actually answer that question we
can talk about the meaningfulness of it
the fact that it's just positioned at
velocities is a reflection of this
underlying symmetry of the theory
Galilean relativity we'll get into
symmetries again more later in the
series of videos but now let's switch
gears a little bit to do to sort of dig
into this a little bit with an example
because I started by talking about force
and energy and things like that and we
want to dig into whether or not these
ideas are really necessary or are they
just useful after all you know for force
we said F equals MA force equals mass
times acceleration we also said that if
you are under the force of gravity the
forces Newton's constant times the mass
of the object pulling you times your
mass over R squared so F equals MA and F
equals this stuff so you can just say
that the acceleration is Newton's
constant times
big heavy mass over r-squared the little
M's cancel right and the force goes away
so this is the real physical thing
that's going on you're being accelerated
by an amount that depends on how big the
thing like the Sun or the earth is it's
pulling on you and how far away you are
from it did we really need to talk about
the notion of force at all
and likewise energies are sort of the
same thing we can talk about it seems to
be useful but we don't need to so is it
real because it fundamental is it
important are there force and energy
really central or are they just useful
this might be an important thing going
forward so let's get into this by
relating force and energy by looking at
a simple example this is sort of a
paradigmatic thing to do in physics a
ball rolling on a hill so this is the
position of the ball X and this is the
height of the ball so here's the ball
okay
and it has some position and it has some
ability to roll up and down and this is
a spherical cow landscape a spherical
cow hill so there's no friction no noise
the balls not gonna fall apart it gets
stuck or anything like that okay we're
just gonna solve the equations for
solving equations but in principle you
would just solve Newton's equation to
find out what would happen to the ball
so this is the height above ground H
right this is the height of the ball
right there H for that ball right there
so the height is a function of X that
we're not going to think about the ball
is leaping into the sky or anything like
that so if you know where it is an X and
you know how high it is above the ground
so if we come across a ball sitting on a
hill like that you know what's gonna
happen if the ball is just stationary if
you set it there and let it go you know
it's going to move it's going to start
accelerating it's not on an inertial
trajectory okay so clearly there is some
force acting on the ball let's uh that's
a race of this so I can do a better job
of showing you what the force is there's
certainly a gravitational force pulling
the ball downward and the strength of
that gravitational force is proportional
to the mass of the ball and something
called G G is just the strength of
gravity here on earth we're here on
earth we're on Mars or Jupiter or
anything like
okay there is also a force that is
perpendicular to the surface that the
ball is rolling on so this is called the
normal force F n for normal why is it
called a normal force not because it's
not abnormal because it's ordinary
normal is a fancy math way of saying
perpendicular to so the force that the
hill is exerting on the ball is always
perpendicular to the actual slope of the
hill itself so if you take gravity which
is always pulling you down and the
normal force which is always
perpendicular to the slope of the hill
they cannot exactly cancel because
they're not pointing in opposite
directions there will always be a
remnant force going this way and that
will accelerate the ball down the hill
in fact you can figure out how strong
the normal force is by knowing that the
ball is not gonna fly up into the air
or tunnel down into the earth it will
always keep moving on this trajectory
sticking close to the landscape and so
that's how big the magnitude of this
normal force has to be so from the F
equals MA point of view there's a very
natural story to tell here we started
with a position X we started with the
height we started with zero velocity we
can calculate the force there's going to
be an acceleration the velocity will
change and the ball will roll down the
hill along some trajectory good that's a
good way of talking about it we remember
we mentioned something called the
kinetic energy way back in the first
idea video it's the energy of motion and
for those of you who are fans of
equations it's one-half MV squared but
when you start the velocity is zero so
the kinetic energy is exactly zero
there's nothing happening to this little
ball but as it goes it's accelerating
the velocity is going to change so the
kinetic energy is going to increase with
time so because there is a force acting
on this ball the kinetic energy is not
conserved you will therefore not be
surprised to learn that there is an
extra part of the energy that adds up
with the kinetic energy to make a
quantity that is conserved and that
is the shrink you hear a little bit so
you can see the potential energy the
potential energy is the energy that just
depends on where you are and your
intrinsic property so like your
potential energy might be different if
you're a charged particle in an electric
field at a neutral particle at the same
place but given your properties all you
need to know to figure out the potential
energy is your position so we call it
the energy of your location where you
are and in this particular setup the
potential energy of the ball on the hill
is just the mass times that strength of
gravity times the height and the height
of course is going to depend on where
you are
MGH H of X okay this curve is H of X the
height of the landscape as a function of
X and so the total energy e total is
kinetic plus potential and that is
conserved oops so what happens as the
ball rolls down the hill it starts with
zero kinetic energy and some potential
energy and that potential energy is
converted into kinetic energy the
potential energy is large when H is
large right it's proportional to H and
it gets smaller as you go downhill so
given this spherical Cal setup where
there's no friction by the time you're
at the bottom of the hill you'll have a
lot of kinetic energy in fact you'll
have exactly as much kinetic energy as
you used to have potential energy the
difference in potential energy has all
converted into kinetic so it's
interesting because we needed like add
this extra term to make the energy
conserved I'm not going to derive this
but you can take my word for this this
is actually conserved and so we can ask
you know what is the relationship of
this energy language this energy
vocabulary to this force vocabulary you
know we didn't need to talk about the
energy to solve for the entire
trajectory of the particle right if we
just had done Newton's laws that equals
MA we could have said everything that
there was to say but we get some insight
by talking about the energy so I just
gave you a little bit of insight right
like it given that it's
arts right here when it's right here I
could figure out what the potential
energy would be if the ball were here
and I know that energy is conserved so
once the ball rolls to that point and is
now moving along at some velocity I
should draw the velocity this way
because that's how we moving then we can
figure out exactly what that velocity is
just using energy conservation and the
change in potential all of its potential
energy was converted into kinetic energy
so even though you know we don't need to
invoke the word energy we can just use
forces to a little extent the opposite
is also true there are some questions
that we can answer without mentioning
the word force we can start up here with
a certain potential energy answer the
question how fast will the ball be
rolling when it goes to the bottom of
the hill just using energy conservation
we don't even need to mention the word
force having said that of course it
seems like the energy vocabulary is a
little bit less powerful because it
doesn't give us the entire trajectory
right it doesn't tell us everything the
particles doing if you just put the
particle there with zero velocity and
you say energy is conserved and that's
all you tell me well the energy could be
conserved if the ball just sits there
not moving right that's perfectly
allowed zero kinetic energy potential
energy stays constant so everything is
fine so there's many more ways for
energy to be conserved then there are
real honest-to-goodness trajectories of
the particles so it seems like the force
language is a little bit more powerful
than the energy language when it comes
to asking about problems like this but
it turns out yet again that there's
another relationship that we didn't
mention the we can ask you know we
talked about the force in terms of
adding up the force due to gravity and
the normal force but there's another way
of thinking about where the force comes
from the force acting on the particle is
minus the slope of the potential
so if we give a name to this let me uh
usually the letter that is given to this
is V of X is the potential energy so V
equals M times G the mass the particle
times the strength of gravity times the
height above the ground so minus the
slope of the potential mathematically
that's minus the derivative of the
potential with respect to the position
again if you're not a math person just
don't look at that part okay but still
you can see this kind of makes sense the
let me zoom in here so the slope this is
a point right here where the ball is
where the slope is going upward right
it's moving upward the landscape the
height above ground is increasing as x
increases the force is going in exactly
the opposite direction so the force goes
down it's minus the slope if you were
down here near a point where the slope
was essentially zero there would be no
force and in fact you could put the ball
down there you could let it go and it
would not move there's no force on it so
this relationship the forces minus the
slope of the potential energy gives you
a little bit more clue that energy is a
little bit more powerful than we thought
of course we don't need to use the word
energy we can just talk about the forces
but if you just tell me what the
energies are I could figure out the
forces in this particular situation so
maybe there's sort of more information
being hidden in the energy than I let on
can you you might want to ask can you
replace the notion of energy the notion
of force entirely in favor of something
there's more energy like let me before I
answer that question I remember that's
one other thing I want to tell you we
have a feeling that objects that real
balls in the real universe will roll
down the hill to the bottom and then
they will stop and maybe they'll bounce
around a little bit but then they will
settle down to the minimum that will go
down to the valley and settle at the
lowest point of course you can
understand by now that that's just
because the ball is not in a spherical
cow you know
the real world is not spherical cow land
there is friction there is noise etc in
this slippery world it would just slide
right on by and go up the other side but
still there's a remnant of that idea if
you think about the forces minus the
slope of the potential if you were to
give in to the temptation to assign you
no purpose and meaning to the life of
this poor little object that's just
obeying the laws of physics you would
say well the fact that the force is
minus the potential is saying that the
ball kind of wants to decrease its
potential energy if you put the ball
there stationary not moving it wants to
move in the direction where the
potential is lower it doesn't really
want to do anything the ball doesn't
have any desires or anything like that
but it begins to move in the direction
where the potential is lower because
energy is conserved in the spherical cow
world it won't actually stop it will
keep going but then once it's passed
once the ball is up here and still
moving in this direction this is the
velocity of the ball here but the force
is now acting in the opposite direction
because the force is gonna want to pull
it back to where the potential is at a
minimum so there is some kind of quasi
teleological language sneaking in what
does the ball want to do what direction
does it want to move in things want to
move in the direction in which their
potential energy is less that's another
little bit of insight to me the
relationship between these concepts okay
how far can we go in relating energy and
force in this way we can go very far as
long as you're willing to stretch your
mind in a little Mathia direction okay
let me tell you what I mean by that I
want to talk about the space of all
trajectories we already said that a
space is just a mathematical way of
saying a collection of things with some
extra structure so consider all possible
trajectories
between we're not going to think of all
the trajectories of everything in the
universe we want between two points that
we specify at two times in other words
imagine once again space-time we're
imagining that we have some location X
naught at time T naught I don't know why
we just don't say zero we'd like to say
not in these situations and then we have
some other point here there's a new
location X 1 at time T 1 and we say
think about all the ways you could get
from there to there ok so you could take
a straight line more or less or you
could sort of stay linger on close tag 0
for a long time and then very quickly
move over or vice versa so you could
very quickly move over and then stay
stationary or you go way out here and
then way back and go something silly or
you could just jiggle back and forth in
a crazy way all sorts of things you can
do the only restriction is you better be
going upward in this diagram you not to
travel backward in time sorry about that
but there are many many ways to get from
a certain point at a certain time to
another point at another time which one
is the one that the object will actually
take if it's moving in some particular
potential some potential energy
landscape if it's a ball rolling a hill
or if it's an electrical charge being
pushed by an electrical field or if it's
a planet in the solar system or whatever
given the laws of physics given the
forces okay that act on it what are the
trajectories that it could take note
that I set things up a little bit
differently so I never mentioned
velocity here I'm not giving you this is
no longer working with in the Newtonian
laplacian paradigm antonio flossing
paradigm i give you the position and the
velocity or momentum at this initial
point and then i chug forward in time
here i'm saying i give you just the
position at one time and just the
position at another time so i'm
replacing the information that is the
initial velocity or momentum with a
different bit of information some
subsequent position
so I'm giving you the position at two
different times rather than the position
and velocity at one time it's the same
amount of information you know
information is conserved in laplacian
way of thinking about things
but I'm replacing positional momenta
initially with position initially and
also position finally it's three numbers
in three-dimensional space either way so
plausibly I can answer this kind of
question but the laws of physics as
we've set them up do not have quite the
ability to answer it easily maybe
there's another way and I want to I
should sort of pause to talk about math
a little bit what is math I don't know I
have no idea what math it's not gonna
try to define math but I've noticed over
the course of my career one thing that
mathematicians love to do is to talk
about maps between different spaces very
close to a large fraction of math very
close to a 100% fraction of math is
thinking about different maps between
different spaces so mathematicians will
very often take something where you
thought everything was easy and they
will state exactly the same thing but in
a much more high-powered way which makes
it seem harder but generalize is much
more straightforward lead to more
interesting situations so for example
the position of a particle how do you
think of that in the back of your mind
well you might say here's space
three-dimensional space which I draw a
little two-dimensional thing and there's
an element of that two-dimensional space
which is the location of the particle
right that's the position that's how you
would think about it you think of a
space and an element so once you become
more mathy about it do you think ah
there is space exactly the same way I
had before but then there is a point the
point represents the particle space
represents all of the conceivable
locations where the particle might be
and there is a map from the point into
space called the location map so I can
think of the location of the position of
a point as a map from the set of the
point which is just a point
to space itself now that's just silly
right like if that's all we were doing
we wouldn't really think very hard about
this this is this is just unnecessarily
complicating things but when you get to
trajectories it's a little bit more
sensible
so trajectories it's bad handwriting
sorry for trajectories what we what do
we mean we again have space but we think
about an interval of the real numbers
okay so here's an interval let's say
from zero to one does it have to be from
zero one between one number one real
number and another one some interval and
we map that interval into space and what
we get is a parametrized curve where the
parameter tells us which of the places
we started on in that interval so you
can think about this parametrized curve
is representing time and where you get
mapped to as representing space so it's
a slightly nice way of thinking about
the space of all trajectories the space
of all the different ways you could map
an interval into space itself I know I'm
using the word space to mean two
different things and where we really get
big is to think of functions on the
space of the directories
yeah sorry about that too ambitious
space of trajectories
so we mean by a function is for every
element of the set I assign a number so
basically I have the space of all
trajectories and I map that to the real
numbers real numbers are denoted R so
for every trajectory I assign a number
like the length the distance traveled or
the time something like that there's all
sorts of numbers you could assign to the
space of all trajectories so why am I
telling you all this why am I going to
all these details to give you a tiny
smidgen of insight into how
mathematicians think and talk it doesn't
seem to get us anywhere immediately but
if you think about it the way that we
were doing physics in the Newtonian
laplacian way of doing things brought us
right up into calculus right how to
calculate the rates of change of things
find the minimum of something the
minimum of a curve is gonna be a place
where it's flat okay where it's slope is
zero and therefore you can get there by
taking a derivative and setting that
equal to zero getting an integral to
find the total amount of change
something's undergone it's all calculus
and all of this fancy-pants stuff
enables us to do calculus in a much
bigger context we can do calculus not
just for one particle moving in one
direction or in several directions in
space we can do calculus on the space of
all trajectories okay we can take
derivatives of functions on the space of
all trajectories why in the world you
might say we want to do that well we do
that's exactly what we want to do as
this way of really turning energy into a
totally new way of formulating classical
mechanics this way is called the
principle of least action
so the idea is exactly as we set it up
before let me see if I can do something
fancy here and copy this how about that
technology at my finger prints at my
fingertips good tada
there we go so here is the space that we
have very very abstract notion of space
the set of all trajectories between this
location in space and this point in time
my claim is there is a number a function
a number we can assign to each path to
each trajectory called the action and
the point is that there's an action for
every single possible path and the
actual path that the actual object takes
will have less action than any other
path so you're considering the space of
all possible paths you know how quickly
you can go from one place to another
leaving at the same point to this
certain time coming back to a different
point at a different time and you say
that there is an accumulated number
called the action that you assign to
each path and it's lower for the real
path the actual path that's taken than
any others what is this number well
before I tell ya I'll tell you what the
number is the number the action is the
integral the total accumulated over the
whole path of the kinetic energy minus
the potential energy so it's not an
energy all by itself right an energy
would be the kinetic energy plus the
potential energy this is and the energy
is a number at any one point along the
path the action is a is a quantity along
the whole path that you get by
integrating so if I were for you math
geeks out there it's the integral of the
kinetic energy minus the potential
energy over time and this quantity right
here is called the Lagrangian after
mr. loo garage I think I'm gonna forget
mr. Li garages first name but this idea
of something like a principle of least
action it has a complicated history it's
often given credit to Moe Pertwee
but people like Euler Lagrangian William
Roman Hamilton who we'll get to later on
lots of people talked about this kind of
thing so the idea is I'm not going to
derive anything sorry about that but the
idea is given that for at any one point
along a trajectory we have a position
and a momentum so we can calculate the
kinetic energy and the potential energy
then we can add them up along the path
and the Lagrangian which is a thing
we're adding up along the path it's sort
of once to be as small as possible or at
least it's accumulated amount which is
called the action once to be as small as
possible you're missing out so I can't
actually derive it here I'm not going to
actually derive it here I could but you
have to trust me this is actually true
and let me let's just give a little bit
of insight into why this would be true
Alyssa how it works not really why it's
true so if you think about our example
of particle rolling in some potential
okay here we go
you might say all right I have a
particle here I'm gonna let it go it's
gonna roll down to here so this is x1
let me start this is x2 or sorry I said
that we were calling this X naught this
is x1 and we do this at some time T
naught and we finish at some time T 1
yeah okay here's what you might be
thinking you might say well if I let the
particle go in Newtonian mechanics in
the atony way of thinking about things I
can figure out how fast it goes and it
will roll down the hill it will
eventually get there and after a certain
time which I can calculate it will reach
that point x1 but here you're doing
something weird you're telling me ahead
of time not just the points of the
locations where you start an end but
also the times when you start in what if
it doesn't take that amount
- time what you're saying here is that
if you fix this time so let's say that
there's a real time you would take if
you started at rest to get to that one
point well what if I gave you a shorter
amount of time then you could infer that
the real trajectory that was taken is
one where you started going down the
hill faster you started going down the
hill at some nonzero velocity to begin
with so you can't implicitly say in this
least action way of doing things you
can't say I start here with zero
velocity you don't give me the velocity
I solve for what the velocity has to be
in order to fulfill the requirement that
I start at point x naught at time t
naught and end up at point x one at time
t1
likewise if it takes longer if i give
you a longer interval of time than it
would take to get from X naught to X 1
then the particle starts by going up the
hill by wasting its time and then by
coming downhill by taking a longer
amount of time to do that and what it's
trying to do as that happens so if you
try to minimize kinetic minus potential
energy what does that mean sort of
physically well minimizing the kinetic
energy means move as slowly as possible
okay but you can see that there's a
constraint you have to move fast enough
to actually get from X naught to X 1 so
you can't just move at 0 velocity that
would not fulfill the requirements what
we say the boundary conditions the
conditions that say you are at point x
naught at time t naught and at x 1 at
time t 1 if you don't move you're not
going to do that so you have to move a
little bit there has to be some positive
contribution to the kinetic energy but
then it's also minus the potential
energy so potential energy goes up as
you go up the hill if you want to
minimize the action you can do that by
maximizing the potential okay you want
to be at larger values of the potential
to actually get lower and lower maybe
even negative values of the action
there's nothing wrong with the negative
value of the action so you might say
well why doesn't the particle just go
way up to huge values what if what if
this curve just continues on for a very
long way infinitely far up couldn't you
just minimize the action by going up to
huge values of
potential well no because it would take
a lot of velocity to get up there in the
time you are allotted so there's a
competition the particle wants to
minimize its action by maximizing its
potential so it wants in this weird way
of thinking of it to go up the hill but
it also needs to get down here to point
x1 at time t1 and it's not going to do
that if the velocity is going in the
wrong direction so even though it's a
very different way of thinking it
actually does hang together intuitively
this whole idea of the principle of
least action the reason I'm doing it the
reason why I'm going through all of this
slightly abstract high-powered way of
thinking is because none of this uses
the word force anywhere right we define
the action in terms of the kinetic
energy and the potential energy the
kinetic energy you need to know what the
velocity is and you need to know what
the position is for the potential energy
so the the basic features of the state
of the particle are still there but we
didn't use the use the word force
anywhere we just use these different
energies and combine them to make the
action and we minimized that action so
you can recover all of classical
mechanics this way
classical mechanics a la principle of
least action is precisely equivalent to
classical mechanics Allah the Newtonian
laplacian paradigm but they use very
different concepts to make them up
another way of thinking about it is that
the word action is supposed to give you
an impression of something it's supposed
to be evocative along the history of
this subject people invented words like
effort to mean the same thing
it's a it's a way maybe to think about
it is that nature is as lazy as possible
nature is trying to do something as
little as possible and this is just the
quantitative way of summarizing what
that something is that something is the
action or was someone once called the
effort it's very closely related to a
earlier principle by Pierre Fairmont of
FAMAS Last Theorem theme ver mas
principle was in a much more
highly circumcised context but it was of
least time so what he imagined was a
beam of light okay so was not supposed
to be for any kind of physical system in
particular a beam of light so let's
imagine you had you know some water and
you had a beam of light that was emitted
here so here's a flashlight admitting
beams of light and they're observed here
so here's an eyeball measuring does the
light go on a straight line through the
water this is air this is water no it
does not because the speed of light is
different in water than in air if you've
ever been told the speed of light it's
always constant that's because the speed
of light in vacuum in empty space is
constant but the speed of light is a
little bit slower in water than in air
so for mots principle is that you know
how light actually refracts it actually
bends when it goes into or out of water
to air and so from what figured out a
way of calculating exactly what the real
path was something like this by noting
that the light beam spent less time in
the water than it did than it would have
on the shortest distance path but it
also moved more slowly so in some sense
the light beam is saving time by moving
on this trajectory rather than this
straight line at the straight line would
minimize the distance between where you
begin and where you end but it would
take longer because it's spending more
time in the water where the speed of
light is slower so this is this is maybe
the first example of a minimization
principle in physics giving you a simple
law the principle of least action is
sort of the generalization of this and
so it reflects this idea that there is a
sense in which nature is lazy nature's
trying to do the minimum thing here
nature is minimizing the time it takes
to go from where you admitted the light
where you absorbed it here nature's
minimizing this particular integral of
the potential energy minus the kinetic
energy minus the potential energy yet
another way of saying the same thing is
just think about you know
forget about like going through water
and air think about like going through
just empty space right we say it goes on
a straight line and you could think of
that as not just light but particles go
in straight lines etc we think of that
as momentum is conserved there's
momentum pointing in some direction and
it just keeps going in the same
direction but we also know that the
straight line is the shortest distance
path between two points so we can think
of the space of all possible ways that a
ball or a light beam or anything like
that could get from one point to another
the real physical one in the absence of
any forces is the one that minimizes the
path length so the least action
principle is it is a generalization of
that but the thing that is being
minimized is the action rather than the
path length so the reason why it's a
little bit tricky is because this is not
the Newtonian laplacian paradigm this is
not an initial value problem okay we're
not saying let's look at this diagram
again we're not saying I give you the
position of velocity at the initial time
and then chug forward one by one I give
you a piece of information now and a
piece of information later and I solve
for everything that happens in between
and this is completely equivalent to the
Newtonian laplacian way of doing things
so maybe it'll pause just isn't the
right way of thinking about it right
rather than saying well there's
something that we know at the current
time that implies everything about the
future maybe there's something that we
know about the past and the future that
implies everything in between and the
answer is it's either way it's neither
one of those is right or wrong when we
go back to the question that motivated
us from the beginning of this video is
force real is it fundamental is it
necessary what about energy is that real
is that fundamental is that necessary
neither one of these are real
fundamental necessary in the strictest
construal but there's another sense of
which they clearly are real something
can be not fundamental or necessary in
the sense that there's a different way
of talking which that thing doesn't
exists and yet that thing is real right
this table in front of me is real here
it is I'm
touching it and putting things on it if
I want to talk about the quantum
mechanical theory of the universe this
is just a little sub factor of the wave
function of the universe right I would
never talk about a table at the level of
the quantum mechanical wave function of
the universe and yet here it is real the
same thing is true for things like
forces and energies these are ways of
talking about things the universe does
the universe is real at the fundamental
level I'm gonna you know make a bold
philosophical claim and the philosophers
watching can disagree the comments at a
fundamental level the universe is real
in a way that nothing else is none of
the other words that we use to describe
the universe quite had the level of
reality that the universe itself does so
when you talk about things like energy
and force even position and momentum and
things like that those are useful ways
for we human beings to describe the
universe and useful isn't meant for
being just subjective and arbitrary it
really is a metric it's a it's a way of
measuring how helpful things are to us
because of the amount of information
that this concept conveys remember we
said that force conveys a lot of
information because it's a function of
the positions and velocities of
everything else and from that function
you can figure out the acceleration and
that's all you need here we don't use
that force was not necessary it was not
built-in in an irreducible way through
the fabric of reality but we had a
replacement for it right the action the
kinetic energy the potential energy
played the role in the least action
principle that force plays and Newton's
laws so the world is what exists all
these words that we use to talk about it
all these concepts we use can be very
very helpful and if our motivation here
is going forward trying to improve our
current understanding of the laws of
physics we have to be open to the
possibility that we're gonna invent more
words more concepts more ways of looking
at the same universe that help us recast
those laws extend them generalize them
go beyond what we currently know into
the physics that we don't yet understand
but hope someday to do